[موسيقى]
مع دخول شهر رمضان يفيد الى الحرم المكي
اكثر من مليون و 200 الف معتمر ومصلي
يوميا بعدها تشغيل الحرم المكي هذا الموسم
بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه ما جعل رئاسه
الشؤون الحرمين والقطاعات الامنيه المختصه
باداره الحشود تعمل وفق خطط نوعيه لتقطيع
عمليات التدفقات البشريه وادارتها تخطيط
ليس لخطه واحده لخطه للطوارئ خطه وقت هطول
الامطار خطه الطوارئ وقت زياده الكثافه
العدديه بعد كل صلاه يتم فتح صحن المطاف
مباشره يعني اثناء الصلاه يتم فتح الحواجز
مجرد ما المعتمرين يصلون في الدور الارضي
او في المناطق الخلفيه من الدور الارضي
على طول بعد الصلاه بامكانهم التوجه
مباشره الى صحن المطر
14 مسارا بالمسجد الحرام لدخول وخروج
المعتمرين والمصلين وكوادر بشريه مؤهله
تدير المسارات وعمليات التفويج الى صحن
المطاف اضافه الى مراقبه الكثافات عبر
غرفه العمليات والتاكد من ثلاثه التنقل
للمعتمرين اثناء اداء النسك صحن المطاف
والدور الارضي للمعتمرين الدور الاول وسطح
المطاف للمعتمرين والمصلين الساحات
الخارجيه والتوسيعات السعوديه الثالثه
بساحاتها للمصلين هناك فئه من المعتمرين
يرغب في صلاه القيام مثلا او صلاه
التراويح هناك بعض المساحات تم تخصيصها في
صحن المطافي في الدور الارضي في المناطق
الخلفيه
لصلاه المعتمرين خصصت وكاله التفويز
واداره الحشود بالرئاسه العامه اكثر من 4
موظف ميداني مؤهلين ومدربين على مهام
تنظيم دخول وخروج وتنقل المعتمرين
والزائرين داخل المسجد الحرام وذلك عبر
ممرات ومسارات وابواب جهزت لخدمتهم ووفق
معاييره ونسب تراعي الخطط التشغيليه من
الحرم المكي سلطانه السلمي العربيه